there is zero reason ever to verbally
undress someone in a meeting I would
love for somebody to stand up right now
and explain to me why being mean in a
business meeting brings any value it's
just completely logical I understand why
people do it fear is a motivator in the
micro short term it is the most
disgusting weapon that a human can use
if you sit here today and know maybe
because of the way you were brought up
and the way you were managed or the DNA
you got from your grandma it happens
that you use fear you really should be a
taking a step back and reconsider that b
you should be ashamed of yourself for
ever using it again and see if you don't
know how to solve this figure it the
[__] out